last week French artist Brigitte
Bartolome was walking along the
southwest coast of France when she found
a message in a bottle inside was a
detailed drawing of a corner a type of
seabird George Barozzi an artist from
New York City drew that cormorant back
in 2013 then he rolled it up put it in a
bottle sealed it with wax then he hurled
it into the Atlantic Ocean he was
sending out an SOS but it wasn't because
he needed rescuing it was he hoped a
message about the increasing problem of
trash in our oceans and how it affects
sea life like cormorants his project is
called New York pelagic over the years
he's thrown out over 20 bottles and had
about a third of them discovered inside
each bottle is a drawing of a different
seabird with information about the
project plus a link to his website the
bottle found in France has made big news
there and spurred a conversation about
ocean pollution not bad for a social
media platform that takes three years to
reach its audience